smith alhamdulillah welcome to the Dean
show thank you for tuning in exciting
exciting we're talking about in the club
that's right we know we've done episodes
in the past and we know that life is not
about the Harlem shake okay you know I
had one of my instructors put that guy
to sleep you can watch that on YouTube
too so we ended that but when we know
what the purpose of life is we'll know
what it's not and it's not about going
to the club so if you're preparing to go
for the club to the club I'm sorry just
hold on a second until you watch this
show very exciting i got the author of
the war within the hearts habib Kadri
here with me on the D show don't go
anywhere
this is the thing
this is the video this is the days of
the dangers the video this is the things
welcome back to the Dean show my special
guest Thank You Salaam alaikum why they
come so please be with you please be
with you soon thank you for being with
us here on a Dean show I got so much to
talk to you about because I think this
is a very relevant topic in today's day
and age where people are lining up to go
to the clubs that's great right and
we're talking about the club's is and
you heard me mention when I open the
show we talked about the Harlem shake
right all right hey you remember that
yes it is you know one foolish thing
just took off and everybody's acting a
clown they don't have the blueprint to
life so it just you know do things as
you wish as you want that's right it
doesn't matter you know what are the
consequences but we know when we're
living the way of life from the crater
there are consequences there are there
is a blueprint and I think your book
addresses many of these issues that I'm
challenges today facing the you've what
motivated you to write this book yeah I
myself was born in Chicago you know
first generation my father came in the
you know the 60s so going through
chicago chicago public schools you're
from Chicago you know from from
kindergarten all the way to high school
and and seeing some of the challenges
that many of our young Muslim youth even
when I grew up faced a lot of times with
fate you know dealing with different
situations and I know one of the big
things was you know a lot of times we
think of when you're getting you know
are the challenges not sometimes it's
physically but it's really the spiritual
challenge especially with the Dean or
it's not just believing in guys but
putting it into action or if you really
do believe in allah subhan time and so
there I realized that hey you know going
through asking why we can't do this
while we can't do this and I felt that
sometimes the answers I know Allah has
the answers but sometimes our scholars
are sometimes have a hard time
explaining that to our young youth so I
decided as I grew up in some of the
things I've seen some of the friends
that have enough
I have encountered and thought you know
it'd be a time when you know to go ahead
and write it now working with youth for
for the last 20 years I felt that this
was a something that hopefully in sha
Allah can hopefully better me and make
myself you know remind what a duties for
Las pantalla and also my other youth but
their duties for Las wanton and
hopefully help them and with any
struggles that they have in there and
within their hearts just for we have a
big audience of not yet Muslims because
everyone has the potential to submit to
God someone heard you say Allah right
please define that for Allah is the
Arabic word for God it's the same guy
that in the Christian faith and the
Judaic faith so you know and so God
Almighty is this the same guide of all
the other prophets from Adam Abraham
Isaac Noah Jesus and so on so that
Starling meant because when you look at
the Christian Bible yes you'll see in
the first chapter the first page on
Genesis a law is mentioned in the Arabic
Bible that Christian and Jews read Allah
has mentioned 17 times that's amazing
right amazing because when people try to
make it out like this is some some some
foreign God yes it's the same God of all
the Abrahamic faiths yeah so tell us now
you grew up here yes you understand the
culture the environment yes so now you I
was just to bring people up to speed out
we met and I know you from Chicago we
met at a conference a convention Orlando
yes forget you you gave me a wonderful
gift yes the your book and I started
reading it oh and i came back i said
this is what we have to talk about these
are topics that you know are addressing
the youth and the problems and you go
over them in such a beautiful way and
one of them is you know there's so many
i really want to encourage people to get
this book to buy it but it's in the club
that's right how'd you come up with this
in the club in the club in the club is
something like you know you know
everyone wants to go into the club and
there's a rapper by the name of 50 cent
so if you look at me chapters of the
book they're kind of a little you know
various songs are some you know slayings
I kind of used those just to kind of get
the kids to like wait a minute yeah in
the club so it was really caught from
there but the idea of was just you know
kind
how do I say Friday night Saturday night
parties in a more catchy way so in the
club became through one of the songs
that you know that the kids were kind of
hearing I'm like wait okay let me use
that as a way to get the kids you talked
about this this clubbing culture yes
talk about that so that you know which
you know in the club is something like
the club is something where if you see
all the vices they're all there right
and one of the things that we wanted
when we started off with that chapter
why we kind of focus it was to really
first find out like an earlier previous
chapter we talked about that when a loss
prompt that gives us an example through
a domani sonam he doesn't say that you
know to Adam don't eat from the tree he
says don't go near it dr. ebook don't go
near it's the same verse and Allah says
laptop labels enough that's a said don't
commit fornication it says don't go near
fornication and so in the club was a
chapter where if you think about it that
what what I beliefs when Allah someone
you know when he asked a lot of
permission to the end of time to take
more people with me you know it least
says I'm gonna come from the front I'm
gonna come from the back I'm gonna come
from the right I'm gonna come from the
lab I'm gonna come in ways that you
don't even know blindsided he's not
gonna die on me please you know come
with me he's going to make himself look
good and in the club is a place where
think about this the whole thing you go
there friday saturday nights first and
foremost still have the opposite gender
it's two groups but always have one
opposite gender for free most of the
time ladies ladies free until 12 of
ladies ladies night our uniform to a
clock ladies are free so now you have
then the opportunity to come in there
but this ik just just to lighten the
mood we have two other things that kind
of get people going the alcohol then you
got the music so it's like you know just
the music kind of gets people because it
does music plays plays with the emotions
then you with that plus the alcohol then
the night the nice setup climbing
culture kevin has that whole little flow
of slowly where your beasts could work
is magic because now the environment is
not about oh don't worry I'm not gonna
do anything wrong i'm just going to come
in just to check out the music yeah but
then this is where all these steps start
to come and come and come come into
action
so a person goes there may be friends
I've seen people I just want to see how
it is that kilometers yes you seen on TV
oh man you know I just want to go check
it out so now you go and then say all
right we'll just go we'll just go and
check out the music just bounce our
heads we won't do anything you know
we'll cover each other sometimes Wilson
Muslims you know what we'll just watch
look we just see what what's what's
wrong with the wild rink I'm not gonna
enter making demands by step and there
you go okay I'm just gonna dance ok I'm
going to just dance moms gonna dance
with you know just by myself right I'm
not gonna dance with the opposite gender
all right I'm going to dance with the
opposite gender but the the and the way
the clubs that they don't have opens
they have small spaces why so everyone
gets close and close it's all set up you
made a great example to talk about it's
not like a tennis match you
disrespecting your spectator right you
know because it's human nature yeah
there's always someone for say there's
always somebody for somebody hey there's
a and you come there yeah you know and
you got these kina individuals you see
this on the video so people equalities
wanna get the get the feel right by just
I just want to go close to just to look
at the treatment why not do anything but
sit at the same time and you come in
there so now you got people individually
then they have you no drinks for free or
drinks for one dollar until eleven or
twelve o'clock because like hey you get
a few sips you're going to come back for
more exactly right they get a little
tipsy then it starts off so not okay
well you know what I'm is gonna dance
but if I do dance I'm not going to touch
if I touch but I'm not going to you know
touch anywhere inappropriate oh but I'm
not going to kiss and just slowly slowly
you know shakedown killing you softly
just it's kind of taking a step after
step and then that's where you start
seeing this whole kind of process of how
you know the club scene is you know it's
it's amazing you gave some wonderful
examples I mean from the verbatim word
of god the Quran that Allah the Creator
is talking about don't come near
fornication come near adults right
because you come near you I mean and you
made a great example in the book that
even the most pious person as you put
them in that atmosphere you're gonna get
comfortable over time right yes and then
your whole Iman and all of the good
things that you start thinking and
feeling it's all out the window now and
you just you just
self in a really bad today's look epic
if there were sahabas at the time the
prophet saw some who committed some
illicit relations and some were you know
you know whipped or whatever the
punishment which they themselves came
sell profit i did this what you know how
can I be forgiven so if we can happen at
that time it can happen in Muslim
countries and now you're putting the
situation where there's hey you're there
where they want you to kind of let's say
hey hang out we're giving you all the
things you need to make it happen I got
you the music I got you some dancing I
got you the alcohol and there's always
some drugs on the side so I'm worried or
you know go right off the street of the
club someone's got in their car some
people might have snuck it in then you
got every avenue and thing that you need
to for you to get to fornication because
what else you're going to apple whoa
whoa everyone's there that already meet
up yeah people are not there just like
and I just want to know if you want to
just talk you could just go to someone's
house watch a game and just you know
shoot the breeze it's an atmosphere set
up for destruction because what happens
then I mean you do the foreign Acacius
and then what happens you might catch a
disease let's go on yeah all the other
things that might happen you know date
rape yes how many women end up at an
after party or even the club they
getting up getting rape you know kids
coming up with without a father
illegitimate children yeah you should we
have I mean just think my statistics
here you got 60 1.8 million girls under
the age of 16 who had kids 1.8 million
right then you have one out of every
five girls in college have at least been
tempted you know sexually assaulted a
lot of times it happens in these places
right where you have one out of every
four kids in high school have an STD
sixties transmitted disease do you think
they want it it's just like oh no way
we're just going to hang out we swim the
boyfriend-girlfriend but we're going to
kiss but now just think how it's
happened and he you know with all these
all this what they're seeing everyone is
like wait a minute wait you're just
boyfriend/girlfriend you haven't done it
like I was in high school and I played
ball guys like wait a minute you don't
they recreate your version like to be
virgins I what's wrong with you it's the
other way it's impala it's it's it's
uncool to be righteous yeah
that's that's like the society culture
and I like what's with you we're going
to take a break / come back you know the
good has been made bad too bad been made
good and we've got everything mixed up
in the wrong way we're going to come
back to talk about more of this in the
club with our guests here the war within
the hearts author we'll be right back
here in the d show so as the last and
final messenger sent to mankind the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him he
told us to really reflect often about
death reflect upon the destroyer of
pleasures many of us are delighting in
our lusts and our passions were chasing
this world we're chasing that dollar
we're chasing all the material things
we're working on our physical physique
and working on our minds with the soul
we're neglecting it so before a
situation comes where you might end up
in a hospital you might end up with no
legs you might end up with no eyes you
might end up in a situation that you
won't be able to even make a prostration
to your crater you won't even be able to
do the things that you're doing now some
of the heart hearts that just have gone
away that they've made money their God
they've made a woman their God they've
made a man their god that's all they
think about is the next party or the
next good time but as you see if
tomorrow you get hit by a truck or a car
or you fall from a fall tall building or
you get cancer or you get a disease that
you're not you're terminally ill and now
you
you lose all these wonderful benefits
take advantage of your health now and
use it in the proper way if you're
Muslim you know that as Muslims we need
to be praying we need to be establishing
a direct connection with our career
minimum five times a day we need to stay
away from the things that are
displeasing to God Almighty we need to
pray to Him alone and not his creation
we need to follow the Sunnah the way of
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind and stay away from gambling and
alcohol and drugs promiscuity there's no
dating in Islam and many of the youth
are caught up on the Facebook and using
them in an unproductive way so if you
see if you're a young boy or young girl
and you have parents and you're
disrespecting your parents as can be you
tomorrow it can be you tomorrow that now
your health that now you might be
playing soccer baseball football and now
you get hit and you end up paralyzed or
you end up getting struck down and
you're in the hospital and it's almost
flat line now is the time that angel of
death can come at any time moloko molt
he's there waiting so are you prepared
for that moment that moment when your
soul will be extracted from your body
are you ready to meet your Creator when
you're six feet under five feet under in
the ground and the dirt is thrown over
your body then it's too late now is the
time
Oh
you
back here on the Dean show we're talking
about in the club and that was actually
a song by famous rapper 50 cents who we
don't want to emulate we don't want to
follow it up not at all because you'll
see you look at many of these people's
lives is upside down yes right drugs
alcohol and when someone doesn't have
that connection with their creator they
don't have peace mhm and these are the
people that we want to emulate is no no
it's not a so tell us now continuing on
with this topic is another thing that's
very true that the way to the Hellfire
we know that every messenger of god came
to the same message worship the crater
not as Christian do good prepare for the
day of judgment correct so there there
are so many things in the verbatim word
of god and the authentic teachings of
the last and final mission prep mohammed
that teach us how to be righteous and
pious and human beings but many people
will say look my intention my intention
is right you know it's not to go there
fornicator not to you know do these
things but look how many people as you
mentioned your book you know the way to
the hell far is paved with people who
had a good intention but in the heat in
a moment that just went out the door
talks about that you know and its really
amazing that's why just going back to
like anyone goes through hot off and it
really talks about how even he believes
that it believes was a knowledgeable Jim
the devil yeah the devil the devil that
think about the devil saw the creation
of adam or so he knew that there's
existence of god and to a point but
what's the underlying if you think one
of the biggest things is arrogance pride
because everyone thinks it's not going
to happen to me just like and when you
talk with kids you see talks look don't
worry it's not going to happen to me i
know i know my limits no need to tell me
anything I know exactly what to do and
that's always a problem because every
person that goes to the club especially
if they have some idea of God in their
mind like okay you know even if i go i
know my limits how many people like I'm
to go once they go twice just like
anything in life like someone takes one
sip you always gonna take a second set
right someone takes a small and
cigarette one time it's most likely that
you know the pump right when I the one
out three people know they're gonna die
from smoking but 3,000 kids start
smoking every single day because like
it's not going to happen to me right 30
million people use drugs but people why
but it's not going to happen to me the
same width is club now so people go
there have
that then someone goes you know what you
got you get one just go over and say hi
I think she's looking at school just
just show that you got you got you got
game since this show you show your swag
group up there this black just is just
get the number to where I will talk now
someone goes up there are you might not
that said people come up to you one
thing I always told parents because you
know you know is that one of the books
we work all you know parenting who say
was easy to say look there going to be
some kids they might not do they'll come
up to you to them it happened to proper
use of my eyes to know where you might
just happen that way but they might come
up to you but now suppose you get that
opportunity how many people could like
wait a min so I went to the club you get
a number from someone our girl is hey
would you like to dance now how am I
gonna be like no because you've got back
okay I don't wanna make her feel bad you
know like oh no I don't really dance
because I'm not supposed to but as for
some easy i'm at the club okay what if
we make sense i get for critical
critical so now you have that and at
that time use at that moment at least is
gonna work he's like I got it out we're
in the zone and and just what's what's I
like so even for a demolished um it
wasn't the fruit it wasn't like whoo
yeah look at this it's good you know
some of us might get tempted indo-pak a
bit of Guyana cool Johnny or gave me or
man it might be that mokuba I know from
Boston Pizza Pizza whatever it is it
could be that can gave me temptation but
wasn't that the fruit that was a
challenge it's like if you eat this you
could live you see all this you could
existence but for life like angels are
right you know I just be here you know
enjoy this it wasn't that up so it's the
same thing here like don't worry we're
just we're just going to Dan something's
going to happen but after that there's
gonna be a conversation yes for dance
what so after a while might be like hey
hey you know hey you don't just get a
drink I don't drink oh really how are
your muscle oh ok bar you must want so
are you supposed to be here Oh you dye
it one lie after another because I gotta
cover yourself that's it your net web
desk you're in a weapon yeah so that was
going to okay we're just gonna you know
I'll just hang out you know just drink
and no problem oh you know I get your
number okay sure but you know then they
like okay I just gave it to him I'm not
gonna call her back but when you get
that phone call he starts the bus was it
just keeps going on just let me say
she's always say how you do it you know
just want to see like she really thought
really I really was a nice
yeah boom capture vice versa goes the
other way you know to you know girls are
like don't worry I know my limits I have
control I could work him you know many
girls when I was in public schools they
always want to get the bad boy why
because they think they could work in
look I got control I could you know I
could change him and you see the guys
play the game straight up players mm-hmm
no I got and they want challenging right
every guy wants to challenge you try to
get someone else so on you so say vice
versa you see both genders always trying
to have that so and it's a it's just
it's it's a it's jumping into a pool
where you don't know how to swim but you
think you're gonna tread water i use a
life vest and get yourself out what are
gonna do you know just think of walking
there look I'm just worried i took
receipt before I walk into this club me
like it would just make you I'm just
think what people used to say being of
these here like man no no no man I mean
we know that people go to the club to
hook up yes right women might go to
flaunt to get attention so you like
attention that's right right and then
the man he's on the hunt well he doesn't
care about that woman he just wants to
get what his desire it wants isn't that
true that's correct so I mean if he gets
it you're just another number he's just
another name in his black book and
that's it and then when you finally
decided to get serious how you gonna get
married tomorrow when you've been passed
around and with all these are serious
Dino I mean these effects have become so
much on both sides so you got guys out
maybe played the game so much now when
they get married in the second ama be
really just want to get old now with
your opposite gender like man this is
not fun oh I have others back of my head
like yeah this used to be like this use
like this and just righteous girl by
she's she's very like uncommon you know
it's because it's she's shy so it's
gonna be a processed in this whole
opposite gender relation so you know
from you know someone's been righteous
so now like this is born what is this
yeah so you got those things now you
have the other way around if you know
hey vice versa get people grow because
might know about you how the game you
played vice versa you have a sister as I
look at you I watch out people and start
talking especially now it's Facebook and
so on and so forth you have individuals
who like now I mean it's come so where
some people are taking pictures of like
yeah now a lot already has a picture of
you now
is telling others so they can all be
witnesses against you on the day of
judgment like you did do this no I
didn't sounds on your facebook there are
countless I mean he just has a time turn
on the news where girls have gone to
these parties you know they get drunk
that's right a boys take advantage of
them take their pictures girls and
committed suicide because it is right so
I mean one of the attributes out of the
many that the crater has he's the most
merciful the most loving so out of his
love then he send us a way of life that
if we live it'll protect us from all
these harms yes and that's and that's
the thing is that somehow our Dean has
things that you know to cut at the roots
because Allah created us right it's just
like someone you know I tell young a
young individuals and unify high school
college guys and saying you know think
of a best car that various me a Mercedes
are whatever Bentley the people who make
the Bentley they tell you what's what
kind of gas you should put in what kind
of tires you should have what kind of
engine they have a pole precise thing
and they tell you and people followed
because they think the person makes it
knows best a lot creators he's alcoholic
and when Allah says look I know you
because I created you I know where your
limits are and if you put bout put push
these boundaries you will fall now
something said well you know what
someone might be tempted by alcohol some
might be a ladies some might be drunk so
some of us you know I would never be
tempted by we will forget our drugs but
the lady situation big time so Allah
knows everyone and that's why Allah says
look in all these areas you got to cut
out the roots because if not I know and
even like this is one unit new video on
YouTube who's call from a guy from Utah
says can can men and women be friends
and he just went around it's like yeah
sada right no no you see I ever goes
like yeah yeah I'm good be friends were
in the same time right when to her the
other buddy or her flat horse she
thought her friend is like a we had
opportunity yeah I would try to hook up
with her yeah she's like and it was just
odd it odd and it's just need to know
this cisa don't because many of them
good intention but naive yes right yes
so men and women let's make a good they
cannot be friends no you I mean its
demands I mean that yeah he's got
something else on his mind I mean when
Allah when the Prophet says I'm talks
about hey when two opposite genders are
together in a room there's hikmah and
wine
saying because one can have the right
intentions but you don't know the other
person's intentions and that's why when
the Dean has rules it makes sense
because it's it really has this idea of
hey you you know yes there's going to be
interaction there's no doubt about it
but the idea front cycle I'm gonna tell
everything about you hanging out at my
bedroom no we're just friends and then
you see this you see it all on TV they
don't like every time there's always
someone who likes someone it's just
there because Allah has put it in our
hearts to have feelings there's nothing
wrong with feelings so if anyone who has
feelings nu it's okay but the thing is
how you act on the feelings is what a
las plantas says hey work and if you
work and you be patient a lost Panther
will give you on all the clubs and
parties you want in gender & shop and
how many haven't heeded that advice from
the Creator from the blast of fun of
moisture and they've been really just
distraught hearts broken yes and buckets
full of tears scarred for life on going
because there's emotional rollercoaster
you know you know more people go to
counseling it's not because of
physically the most emotion emotions
because you're playing with emotions I
thought he liked me now he broke my
trust took advantage of me he's act
ought he was my friend I can't believe
doesn't like me and I now when I went
the extra mile for him because I thought
he really was going to be the one and
you start seeing it now it's happening
in our own community it's a note so it's
not bad but you know for us this is for
everybody this this foundation is still
in the Christian faith energy Davis have
the same rule everyone can benefit yeah
yes and it's and it's in their fate too
so this is not like all the Muslims
everyone had that but now people have
broken and the one thing about our faith
is that we don't change for the sake of
the people people have to check for the
sake of the bong so it does are you from
your Christian background Jewish
background as and people of God
consciousness there's no there's no
dating or had you know these kind of
things that were addressed it's there
too it's the same living a good upright
moral ethical life we'll be right back
with more given the solutions to many of
these ills so you can live a better more
wholesome organic life and having peace
within your heart we'll be right back
with more here nadeesha bismillah al
hamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be with
you desnuda hamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be unto us mala
hamdulillah Salaam alaikum bismillah al
hamdulillah Salaam alaikum peace be unto
you welcome to the Dean show bismillah
al hamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be
with you greetings of peace to everybody
all around the globe as tuning into the
Dean shop
you
back here on the D show in the club
that's the last place you want to be
trust us trust your created trust our
Creator who's sent down the blueprint
and if anyone has a sincere open heart
open mind and if they want the truth is
there and it's easy to comprehend it's
not something that's weird it's not
something that doesn't make sense this
stuff we're talking about makes sense if
you are in the club and you're going and
you're putting yourself in a bad
environment with bad company bad friends
sure you have a bad result a bad side
effects so let's go into my next
question Thursday comes we talked about
earlier that's the club culture Thursday
clubs already she's calling Suzy John's
calling Mike and they're talking about a
man you know they got ladies night going
out and here comes friday and you know
there you go friday or in the club
jersey shore you're trying to gym tan
and get big yeah it's a culture now
that's right how do we snap out of this
yeah you know it's it's if and i think
it's very important for and again this
not just like you know you know this is
not just for high school college this
about anyone any age so you know a lot
of times people you know think like
because a bleez will tempt you at every
part of your life there's no time he's
like you know i'll let him go so and i
think is very important on thursday
friday nights it's very you know i think
one of the biggest key especially when
you're at the 16 to 25 26 and even the
older is to have friends who think the
same because you know you get yes you
have some friends who will help you
academically there are some who are just
physically maybe you know they're good
like at martial arts basketball sports
you know inside you know that's my group
I just hang out there are some guys that
play ball with maybe you know some are
Muslim some anomalous um you know and
but I'm like okay I'm just hoping and
that's it but then you have also others
who have spiritual and you're some
people have spiritual and all the others
and you got to find those there was a
group of individuals and there's
individuals will be at the massage it
and organizations and it's very
important to have that process of kind
of making sure that you're going to keep
yourself busy on those days because your
thing alarm is going to stay home i'll
be by myself that's when you're by
yourself things start with are you like
I'm going to hang out that friend but
I'm trying to make him better
sometimes that other person can make you
get worse and I think that way by itself
is like number one second thing is in
uniform you know for really trying to
keeping your own things as our friends
it's planning some specific events and
sometimes look there's nothing on the
wrong nothing at all in the Dean to have
fun bahaha entertainment so that means
it you know sporting events playing
exercising you know going out try to you
know just sitting you know with your
friends you know you know just hanging
out playing various things you know a
table tennis to uno to whatever
different things that anyone wants to do
I think it's very important to have some
alternatives because that itself like it
helps out second thing is like you know
really yeah God to keep a lot of mine
it's the loss to Los allies one thing if
i see like i want as long you know
individuals is you know your salah is
not working you start seeing other
things fall through because you keep a
lease even if you just pay the farm I
mean always talking I'm gonna just just
get even the five minutes like 5 times 5
25 minutes you tell me 25 minutes or 24
hours you can't give to God what didn't
tell God you know what God you gave me
the nice car the clove good family but
brain to make lots of money exactly and
I can't give 25 minutes right so I think
just that the aspect of keeping God in
mind and making the one that Allah book
you will be challenged and why I'm
really worried about you know friends
because i myself realized when i went
and played ball that had travelled you
know playing like an all-star team for
the stable and I just kind of going and
a YouTube Long Beach Las Vegas Indiana
and you know the guys it's like what do
you want to do now coach would be like
okay you know you got guys okay games
over just make sure come back by 1030-11
o'clock it it's a challenge you know
people i'll come on just this company's
come with us man you you could be the
designated driver driver are the
individuals going to keep us out of
trouble don't people like I can't
justify what you want to do yeah right
but I work with you back I mean like you
know and I think it's very important to
to kind of keep that concept because you
know a lot of times what I've seen is
that they would you know just be like
come on man I mean you know back back
this is I'm doing monday think about
1994-95 like let's say how did I go Mike
you must be game because you don't talk
to
stops is it busy for sure their other
pressure either bike which is proofed or
just say items it's just so we know that
you know you know if you're going to be
are like you know my roommate in the
inside the hotel room doing I want to
make sure you know just kind of playing
with you and then sometimes you start
seeing how the game is played so even
even getting pressured into doing
something so really understanding that
putting yourself in that but the other
thing is the music and and the TV is
very important because why do you get
the idea what is because you see the
videos you see the music and to see the
video like yeah this looks fun this
looks awesome here's anything like even
cigarettes you know they don't make it
look like like someone just on drugs oh
you know you know back in the 80s 90
Caitlin supposed to like cool you know
they'd be like I'm just having fun even
alcohol they don't have people like you
know a commercial they're just falling
apart you know something happening to
them that was to make it look like happy
days are here even so cigarettes you
don't have someone to gain cancer they
make it so that James Bond and make it
look good keep doing those bad things
take it to the N and you're gonna be the
end result up and that's why and it's
very important because i think the TV
music also is something that you have to
be careful what you're wat you know
watch and listen to you because it's
human nature if you listen to the song
you got to start acting it a fact it's
it's there because you hear so many
times it happy not a lot of kids you
know a lot you know you know especially
going to chicago public schools right
there's a lot of language that's used
you might not use at home i know my
parents never used it but you hear it
enough it could become as a part part
part of your language you don't hear
someone whose praise guys he's walk in
and say subhanAllah when hummed a lot
praising the crater as opposed to the
other ones like just like get that money
get there though get that monkey I mean
and the piper exactly and that's going
to take you on a ride that you don't
want to be on there and then you die so
nets that you feel the test I'm
protective celebrity tail the test and
many of us are forgetting that this life
is a test so give that final advice and
tell people where they can get your book
yeah in the last minute we have so hi
mom you know you know just just advice
to all of us you know you know learn
from when Allah gives stories of the
Quran there's there's a reason for it so
learn from Adam of a personal good this
knowledge is not enough
just knowledge is not enough its
implementation of the Dean because I
beliefs had knowledge but his heart
wasn't there and that's why I you know
the whole focus on the book is war with
hearts because you got to check your
heart and you'll know that without
knowledge without implementation is a
slippery slope and it's very important
that to make sure to go ahead and
keeping right friends keeping your
prayers listen you know reading the best
seller you know one of our solutions in
the book is called the best seller which
is the Quran but remember if a page a
day you know you tell the young ones
page a day keeps the ship down away but
this Quran for everyone at every time
and then learn from that even if a
domani some again everything happens
because Allah wants it to happen we got
to learn that if they could get tempted
proper Yusuf I they got time to where he
was being writing someone else or trying
to tempt them so you got to keep these
things in mind of Allah and the Prophet
Muhammad's the last them in his action
and trying to follow in his sunnah and
being around the Shebab and the young
youth who really practice their deed and
so that we got in the book you could get
it at a crow bookstore it's on a
bookstore amazon you could kind of you
know go ahead and get in shell it's also
coming on ebook in the next two months
in sha allah tala i'm very happy but
said that we come in to an end but
inshallah God willing there's so many
chapters I think are relevant for
today's day and age as we can next time
we all got the cover 10 may Allah bless
you for the work you're doing robotic on
what you're doing chawla and hopefully
it benefits all of us and I mean
everyone also make do off for us and all
of us all to protect us from all this
too I mean thank you very much Jessica
hello and thank you thank you for tuning
in to another episode of the Dean show
in the club that's not the place where
you want to be we talked about it get
around good company good friends and
start you got the good intention
everyone is born with original goodness
you want to do good so give birth to
what's inside of you that goodness start
asking the creator for guidance and
he'll facilitate away and put yourself
in good company and put yourself in a
good environment and stay away from
things that would just corrupt yourself
corrupt your soul because at the end we
die and then the test is over and we
don't want to get F
on that test that's from the Creator
because the Hellfire is a place we don't
want to be we want to get to Jenna we
want to get to paradise because that's
forever forever ever yes and that's
where we're all aiming for so inshallah
God willing we can get there we can only
get there with the creditors helps will
continue to ask him and we'll see you
next time here on the Dean show until
then peace be with you kerala
hamdulillah ala allah ha na na na egg
bomb I love egg bomb Subhan Allah
alhamdulillah Allah Allah ha in na na na
egg bomb I love I bound para la
hamdulillah ala ile aha inama one love
egg bomb i love egg bomb ass apparently
when hamdulillah a la illaha illallah
w'allahu egg bomb I love I bomb had a la
man hamdulillah a la illaha illallah
w'allahu akbar i love egg bum soo patent
la joven hamdulillah I'm a la la ha in
na na na egg bomb I love egg bound ha